[Musique]
il enquête
show toujours du
dos
[Musique]
forme de
titres
[Musique]
wolfram bosco
benhamadi
on n'a pas de sens
coco
[Musique]
mon fils
les nouveaux prix nobel de littérature
samir amin
de la ville de sidi mimoun est heureuse
de vous inviter afin de vous nommer
citoyen d'honneur
c'est me reconnais mes doutes oui tu
voisins oui avec les cheveux longs j'ai
pas changer un nom à toi ta vie' un
petit peu monsieur normal c'est la
france ici c'est là toute façon moi j'ai
pas de voiture parce que j'ai pas de
vernis
abc jeudi l'algérie ça fait combien de
temps que tu est parvenu au bled je sais
mais 25 ans oh non embauche on trouve le
chef tu discutes avec lui qui le chef
lui est là avec les roms comme lui l'un
des relais dégage
nous sommes très honorés de
nous attend quelques noms
on est très fiers de vous en algérie
mais est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
bien raconter impayés alors qu'on vous à
l'étranger j'ai vécu ici jusqu'à l'âge
de 20 ans j'adresse des traces commun
chez moi
la famille a mean joe rhythm burqa
famille noté qu'il a quitté le pays et
menace pour les algériens que du mépris
et de rêve
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu es revenu ne dis pas que
c'est pour recevoir une médaille
savez vous aviez fait les manifestations
étudiantes en 88 ça vous dit pas de
venir manifester avec nous j'ai passé
l'âge non mais quoi il n'y a pas d'âge
pour manifester
[Musique]
juré je remettrai plus jamais les pieds
ici
je suis là
quand général de gaulle déjà fait de
discours je n'ai rien compris je vous ai
compris
[Musique]
dutoit le plus fort
qui êtes vous qu'est ce que vous voulez
nous sommes des super héros qui suivent
les ordres au nom de la justice
mais color quoi c'est tout franchement
je suis un peu déçu je pensais que tu
serais plus fort que ça
l'armée du ruban rouge sera bientôt de
retour
l'heure est venue pour les héros
d'intervenir plus tôt style et non j'ai
maintenant la confirmation de quel côté
le mal se situe vraiment qu anne asie
montre nous ton véritable pouvoir
si vous mettez hors d'état de nuire
c'est la cas d'asthme
ragon super super héros
c'est pas un seul expert de la survie
c'est un aventurier de
ma vie j'ai rêvé de croiser la route
d'un homme comme
c'est bon je viens
chaque toit bien baliser le chemin
c'est vraiment du cours pourra t on à
cascade ces mois là bas je suis pas
carté au look d'accord cartographes oui
bon en amérique du sud ont du talent ton
blog excusez-moi des bilingues
surtout face à lemond ban ki moon
[Musique]
ce que je vous demande
mais à l'endroit où vous avez trouvé
cette sacoche
cette sacoche appartenait à mon père
j'avais brodé la jolie brune est monté
au kursaal la salle du
il va vraiment falloir me laisser le
temps de retrouver mes repères la
dernière fois je suis venu si j'étais
seul en plus c'était l'hiver donc savait
rien à voir c'est l'hiver c'est pas
l'hiver cissé c'est l'hémisphère sud on
est en hiver puis des moufles non j'ai
un bonnet veut pas en hiver il a besoin
la police passera dès demain vérifier si
les résidents bien des papiers en règle
faut dégager tout la fille j'ai dit
situé à les amener aux fours lieu sûr
[Musique]
ma pelouse
salueront allez on y va on y va faites
comme chez vous tapez des cafés mais on
débarque pas chez les gens comme ça chez
les gens parce que là on est chez les
gens regardons pas où je croyais que
j'étais chez mon meilleur ami
les invités toi dans certains villages
on n'hésite pas andy des flics chez les
personnes qui viennent en aide aux
réfugiés
c'est rien c'est une descente de police
mais naturellement qu'ils peuvent dormir
ici on va pas les laisser dehors voilà
this is berthe welcome attend bientôt
nos jeunes n'ont pas touché vers boston
à aarberg vers bretonne
le 14 très beau et que tout ça est
mortel qui va m'apprendre comment ça
marche un tracteur
vous toutes et tous vos nobles à gogo ou
pour des rires au sérieux ou sérieux
alors c'est entre 25 et 30 ans
takero tu vois rien j'ai grandi ici
pendant l'hiver
si un jour tu as un cadavre a planqué
j'espère que c'est à moi que tu viendras
demander de l'aide
c'est un jour j'ai un cadavre à planquer
ce sera le tien
faut vraiment être trop pour prendre la
vie au sérieux
[Rires]
[Musique]
jean boulet a la malchance pour tous qui
allait de travers dans made in
[Musique]
fine
seul univers
j'ai trouvé
une véritable pièce porte bonheur
et si la chance c'était quelque chose
qui pouvait tenir dans le monde
et qu'est ce que j'ai fait
je les fais tomber dans les toilettes
[Musique]
a fait tomber ma pièce par bonheur dans
les toilettes
tu viens de parler
il m'en faudrait juste une
[Musique]
c'est terrible ce mode path horriblement
long
les humains n'ont pas le droit de venir
ici c'est une
terre de chance je partirai dès que tu
m'auras donner une autre pièce porte
bonheur il faut commencer par t'intégrer
majestueuse petit troll frôla une pièce
jouée les la nature on est dans le
département où l'on crée la chance les
moudre à gauche c'est la seule créature
qui arrive à sentir la moindre malchance
il ya une malchance ici aussi chance au
dessus la malchance du tournoi
la plus infime quantité de ma chance
pourrait arrêter toute notre opération
c'est dingue comme tu peux être
malchanceux
hyper méga malchanceuse tu va causer une
catastrophe
connexion a été rompu
condamner tous les autres et une vie de
malchance et toi aussi
qu'est ce que tu fais ici
allez bonne chance à toute heure
on fait quoi pour jets
j'avoue que les mots me manquent
[Musique]
père céleste
puissions-nous être vos outils afin de
réparer ce que nous trouvons prisée
au nom de jésus-christ
[Musique]
une jeune femme et sa fille de 15 mois
ont été assassinés chez elle
nous demandons l'aide de toute la
population nous ne sommes pas une
communauté ayant pour habitude de
verrouiller une porte
mais nous estimons qu'il serait
désormais prudent de faire preuve de
vigilance
l'épreuve révélerait des pratiques des
croyances
dont je n'avais que très rarement quand
tu parlais
je me fous que jamais dans passé
vous devriez en faire autant
à la seconde quelqu'un pousser son
regard sur elle
il était sous son charme
il y a une présence démoniaque pour sa
fille et suit ce dossier ne se résume
pas au noir et qui s'en prend à sa femme
ce soit dès que le tout premier signe
d'une valise
il s'était finalement frayer un chemin
tortueux sol pas trop teisseire
ça va au-delà du simple dames ça va au
delà de tout ça en quoi je crois
nbc après lumière cela vous plaît
quand vous voulez
comment définir la mémoire
que nous le voulions ou non que nous
sachions non nous sommes responsables de
ce qu'ils nous unir à demain si mal
[Musique]
tout ça me fait de ce qui nous a
précédés vos papiers et pour partie nous
engageons l'avenir
pour emma cap comme ça
si par deux passes mais tiens par
exemple
[Musique]
comment ne pas être conscients de la
nécessité de nous unir pour nos épaules
et les uns les autres et résister ainsi
[Musique]
un tour autour du totalitarisme
il faut rester ensemble rien ne doit
nous séparer
plus là-bas simone nervi
or beaucoup une annonce très fière de
toi
l'espoir je félicite madame veil pour
son élection c'est dans l'europe que je
le place
l'europe à surmonter la haine et la
barbarie votre travail madame veil la
vocation
ce n'est pas un travail c'est une
vocation le fait de mettre le bordel
faut partir joe wright
vous ne faites pas pas
j'avais ton âge
tous les jours je vois mon
[Musique]
ma force
et mon modèle
tous mes combats c'est peut-être
horaires
[Musique]